[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui je possède
il jette
très juste le jour où il serait alors
répondre
est un temps
prière essentielle
est beau
s'il te plaît
[Musique]
très cool
où le
[Musique]
c'est le
à bientôt monsieur
[Musique]
c'est de la faim
par
être soi-même
[Musique]
et tout
avec quoi pour
fleuve
nous
et déchets de démolition
[Musique]
Simon
avait conduit
la
[Musique]
est un
tu es
de peut
la
qui c'est
à présent
mais le
Oh non
Est-ce que tu vois
[Musique]
un travail
Ah
[Musique]
à présent
elle
yamaha
nous
[Musique]
siège
non
est un
[Musique]
jusqu'à ce que j'espère
voir quand le
ce sera tout simplement possible
qu'est-ce qui se passe ici
tout va bien
être 0
c'est un groupe tellement en difficulté
pour leur
oh oh
[Applaudissements]